rémy dit que mr à l'est républicain de
florange bonjour et me dit merci d'être
avec nous ce matin en direct sur rt
france alors est ce que vous partagez
cette crainte de ses élus de voir les
vaccinodromes sagot citer les doses de
vaccin au détriment des petites
structures de proximité
alors c'est bonjour déjà ce n'est pas
forcément une crainte pour ma part
puisque je suis persuadé que la solution
doit venir de la vaccination
quand il faut vacciner vacciner vacciner
le confinement pour moi est une fausse
solution ou en tout cas une solution de
court terme on l'a bien vu lors des
premier et deuxième confinement donc
toutes les solutions qui peuvent être
bonnes pour encourager cette vaccination
dans tous les pays du monde il ya eu des
vaccinodromes ils se sont développés
pour avoir une vaccination efficace
alors il est sûre il faut aller au delà
il faut que les pharmacies il faut que
les médecins il faut que les pharmaciens
puissent avoir la capacité à vacciner
également dans le monde rural et dans
les autres villes mais il me semble que
pour être véritablement efficace et
rapide les vaccinodromes sont impératifs
mais pas en doute les vaccinodromes mais
c'est peut-être ce tour de passe-passe
faute de doses qui dévoilerait les
petites structures au détriment des
grosses structures
c'est pas une crainte pour moi c'est sûr
en tout cas que depuis le début la
politique vaccinale est minée par
l'arrivée des doses et l'organisation à
dire européenne de cette arrivée des
d'autres qui amène à une forme de
rétention depuis le début on est
dépendants dans la politique vaccinale
de cette arrivée
un gros bug hier soir sur sur les cours
à distance impossible de se connecter
pour les élèves
le ministre de la santé qui a d'abord
fait des accusations d'ingérence
étrangère suivez mon regard
avant de se raviser regardez vous avez
des attaques informatiques
c'est le cas de ce qu'il se passe pour
le cned ce matin où vous avez des
attaques informatiques
apparemment venus de l'étranger pour
empêcher les serveurs de fonctionner le
travail technique est en train d'être
faits pour établir cela fort
heureusement cela ne touche pas tout le
monde partout
alors ministre de l'éducation nationale
finalement a dit que c'était de la faute
des tuyaux votre réaction et me dis
qu'est ce que le ministère a
suffisamment anticipé une question de
préparation évidemment on sait que la
politique éducative du gouvernement et
je pense que personne ne lui en fait
reproche c'est d'avoir voulu maintenir
les écoles ouvertes jusqu'au bout je
pense que le ministre de l'éducation a
été dépassé par la décision et la
situation sanitaire qui a amené à ce
nouveau tour de vis par rapport aux
d'école à in est clair que avant de
lancer une une opération où l'école se
faisait à distance mieux fallu regarder
si les serveurs étaient capables de
d'accepter autant de collection en même
temps parce qu' un petit peu de la
préparation effectivement d'un haut
niveau de votre commune ça se passe bien
comme dans toutes les communes ya eu il
ya eu des soucis
la ville de florange aussi fait le choix
d'avoir des cours à distance
supplémentaire à ce que fait l'éducation
nationale avec une plateforme dédiée qui
qui permet aux élèves de véritablement
pouvoir avoir un support un soutien ce
que plaire à côté par une plateforme à
distance
donc pour le moment j'ai l'impression
que que tout fonctionne plutôt bien
florange
alors les classes de maternelle et de
primaire rouvriront bien le 26 avril
c'est en tout cas ce qu'a confirmé
emmanuel macron avant-hier regarder je
n'ai pas conditionner la réouverture des
maternelles et des écoles puis des
collèges et des lycées à des indicateurs
sanitaires
pourquoi parce que ces trois semaines
d'absence physique de cours sont déjà un
effort important aie my own a conclu
avait bien réussi à se connecter à
l'application my class a à la maison et
on le voit mais c'était vers 16 heures
dont peut-être qu'il y avait moins
d'affluence at-il raison en tout cas le
président de maintenir cette échéance
du 26 avril je crois plus trop aux
échéances qu'on nous annonce au fur et à
mesure des semaines on sait bien que
tout dépend d'une semaine sur l'autre de
la situation sanitaire de l'évolution de
la situation sanitaire
la ville de florange comme bien d'autres
villes avaient organisé plein
d'événements mois d'avril et en mai en
se disant eh ben voilà le gouvernement
nous annonce qu'en avril ça ira mieux
quand marx et qu'en février
la preuve on est en confinement
aujourd'hui tous nos événements tombe à
l'eau
donc j'ai une grande prudence par
rapport aux annonces au 8 avril pour le
26 de riz et pourtant selon les
modélisations l'institut pasteur il n'y
aura pas de retour possible à la vie
normale sans vaccination de masse est ce
que vous y croyez à la tenue des
objectifs du gouvernement
si on arrive à garder un rythme d'une
certaine manière soutenue à 200 ou 300
milles vaccinations par jour
il est mathématique qu'à un moment donné
au mois de juillet nous et nous
arriverons à avoir une couverture
vaccinale important qui permettra de
limiter les risques d'hospitalisation
après il ya un biais sur lequel il faut
travailler c'est la crainte face au raz
de sein
la crainte face au vaccin phase délicate
qui remet en cause d'une partie de la
politique vaccinale
c'est peut-être le seul levier sur
lequel il ya un vrai enjeu et sur lequel
il faut vraiment faire attention
alors selon un dernier sondage est là
dans un français sur cinq dit qu'il ne
respectera pas la règle des 10 km la
majorité ne croient pas à la réouverture
mimer des terrasses et des lieux de
culte des français qui vous l'avez dit
sont aussi sceptiques vis-à-vis du
vaccin est ce qu ils ont raisons d'être
sceptiques quant à cette réouverture
possible à la mi-mai pour les
restaurants notamment
là encore c'est comme pour les écoles le
doute il est là il est là pour une
raison évidente c'est que on nous a déjà
fait le coup plusieurs fois là encore je
fait de reproche à personne mais la
situation est assez instable nos
effectivement a annoncé à mimer le
retour je ne suis pas devin je ne suis
pas dans la prédiction ou dans
l'incantation personnellement et et je
crois ce que je vois aujourd'hui ce que
le voit c'est qu'au premier confinement
nous avait annoncé un mois cofinancer a
duré trois mois
donc là on nous annonce à moins qu'au
paiement
j'ai plutôt tendance à penser que ça va
durer deux mois et les français qui ne
respecteraient pas les cette règle des
10 km il ya beaucoup de verbalisation du
côté de florange pour le moment
j'entends pas encore beaucoup de
verbalisation mais il est vrai que à
florent nous sommes touchés par fellmann
frontalier avec le luxembourg le
luxembourg viennent d ouvrir les
terrasses il y a beaucoup de frontaliers
qui ont décidé et qui le disent
assez ouvertement il 0 au luxembourg
profitant de leur attestation
professionnels pour aller sur les
terrasses profiter des restaurants et ne
pas respecter le cadre du confinement
france et la bavière en allemagne a fait
une pré commande de vaccins russe est ce
que la france devrait en faire de même
elle attend évidemment la validation de
des instances européennes pour se
procurer ces vaccins qu'en pensez vous
je pense qu'il faut être pragmatique
toute solution toute vaccination qui a
fait ses preuves et qui serait validée
par les autorités de santé par ils ont
été effectués doit pouvoir amener à
accompagner cette vaccination de masse
alors on va parler politique à présent
dans son nouvel essai ans intitulé le
jour d'après l'ancien député philippe de
villiers et fondateur depuis des fous
s'est montré particulièrement critique
contre le président a envoyé cet extrait
nous sommes le seul pays du conseil de
sécurité de l'onu qui n'a pas trouvé son
vaccin
la start up nation est en ehpad sous
perfusion macron n'est pas à la hauteur
de sa fonction critique assez dur
justifié selon vous c'est très dur c'est
près du moi je m'attache plutôt au fait
effectivement on est l'un des rares pays
qui n'a pas eu la possibilité de
proposer au monde à la kz1 on est la
sixième puissance mondiale n'avons pas
réussi effectivement ce constat on peut
tous se partager on peut tous le
regretter surtout quand on sait
l'attachement de la france historique
aaa au vaccin d'une certaine manière si
j'ose le dire
pour le reste je ne suis pas sûr que tu
sois dans la main du président la
république ou du gouvernement
il est clair qu'on aurait peut-être pu
donner des moyens je ne sais pas s'ils
ont été donnés l'ensemble des moyens on
n'aurait plus donné est ce que c'est le
le fait de trop vouloir suivre en tout
cas les les recommandations de l'union
européenne il ya eu une organisation au
niveau de l'union européenne qui a
permis une équité entre les pays qui a
fait en sorte que la bulgarie comme la
roumanie
la grèce est le même niveau le même
nombre de vaccins que la france ou
l'allemagne
est ce que c'est a critiqué en valeur
absolue je ne pense pas après il est
clair que et ben ont subi cette
rétention de vaccins quotidienne qui l'a
contraint d'autres vaccinations
donc bon je je là encore je pense qu'il
faut pas le monde peu facile et on verra
après coup qu'il y avait un intérêt à
éviter d'autres clusters européens
d'autres variantes européens en faisant
cette couverture massif sur l'union
européenne où il aurait fallu avoir une
on le voit même sur la question de la
stran etc à plusieurs pays de l'union
européenne ne font pas la même chose
finalement dans les restrictions par
rapport aux âges notamment
est-ce qu'il faut harmoniser en tout cas
cette politique de santé au niveau de
l'europe et et donner une même une même
ligne en tout cas lorsqu'il y a un
problème
j'entendais ce matin juste avant de
venir que la commission européenne a
rappelé à l'ordre les pays européens en
leur demandant d'avoir une vision
commune à il est il est vrai que à
partir du moment où une commande commune
de vaccins qu'on organise la politique
vaccinale sur le vaccin de manière
jaliya coordonnées il est difficile
aujourd'hui se retrouver dans la dent
dans ce jeu du chat et de la souris
qu'on a eu dans cette désorganisation
massif qu'on a eue avec astrazeneca où
chacun des pays a sa propre politique
d'une certaine manière et c'est des
annonces sur un fait une étape pour
ensuite revenir en arrière après l'avis
de la haute autorité européenne de santé
bon voilà effectivement il ya ça
mériterait qui est un minimum de
coordination et à minima de d'accord sur
ce qui est bon de faire pour nos
populations
ou pas alors dans ce contexte de crise
sanitaire l'ancien ministre du reste du
redressement productif arnaud montebourg
estime que c'est marine le pen qui va
gagner en 2022 regard des macros et
détester parce qu'il est arrogant
ce n'est pas un rempart c'est lui qui
mettra madame le pen au pouvoir est ce
que cette crise aura raison d' emmanuel
macron selon vous
est ce que cette crise aura raison d'
emmanuel macron là encore je suis pas
dans l'incantation
je suis pas dans la prédiction néanmoins
ce qui est clair c'est que il ya
beaucoup de griefs à l'égard du pouvoir
- sur le fond de la politique que
souvent sur la façon d'agir sur la
méthode sur l'arrogance à l'égard des
territoires
là dessus il est vrai qu'on retrouve
d'une certaine manière dans tous les
bords politiques à droite comme à gauche
dans tous les publics historique un
passif contre le pouvoir actuel
néanmoins appelé le le cobp à marine le
pen emmanuel macron pour moi il est
mortifère pour le pays il est mortifère
pour les partis politiques
et j'ose espérer que débat des
présidentielles ne se résumera pas un à
ce débat emmanuel macron marine le pen
car pour moi il ne fera pas avancer
notre pays un dernière question alors
qu'on l'est aujourd'hui les
commémoration de la shoah
la maire écologiste de strasbourg a
refusé d'adopter une définition
antisémitisme hier proposé par l'ira
l'alliance internationale de la mémoire
de l'holocauste
à quelle est votre réaction j'ai pas de
réaction particulière on parle d'un
conseil municipal qui l'a refusée une
délibération proposée par une par une
association
il faudrait avant de faire un jugement
de valeur il faudrait vraiment regarder
quelles étaient les propos cette
délibération quelle était cette
définition
je fuis pas je me suis pas renseigné
j'ai vu bien sûr la polémique mais je me
suis pas assez renseignée pour pouvoir
un avis vraiment tranché sur ce sujet là
est ce que le voit c'est que il ya il ya
une vraie polémique c'est sur laquelle
s'est engouffré beaucoup de médias merci
beaucoup et medic merci pour avoir
d'avoir répondu en tout cas ce matin en
direct à nos questions sur arte france
merci à vous